[Musique]
le centre arsenal art contemporain dans
le quartier petite bourgogne à montréal
est composé de trois grandes salles et
dans chacune d'elles on présente
actuellement une exposition qui vaut le
détour d'une part l'exposition immersive
imagine monnaie présenté en primeur
mondiale monnaie et d'une part le père
de l'impressionnisme
mais c'est également le père de
l'immersion il a peint des toiles la fin
de sa vie est consacré à des toiles
créées pour un musée parisien qui
s'appelle l'orangerie qui l'a construit
vraiment comme un espace immersif il
souhaitait que chaque visiteur soit
immergé dans ses toiles
les visiteurs peuvent déambuler entourée
d'écrans géants où plus de 200 tableaux
du maître sont projetés lorsqu'il a créé
ces fameuses toiles pour l'orangerie on
est au début des années 20 la france et
l'europe viennent de traverser une crise
sans précédent c'est la première guerre
mondiale c'est un lieu de sérénité
c'est un lieu dans lequel on peut
s'immerger de manière paisible et je
crois qu'après les deux années que nous
venons traversée
il était important aussi de restituer ce
message
arsenal accueille également elektra la
5e biennale internationale d'art
numérique cette année l'asie de l'est le
japon la chine et la corée sont à
l'honneur sous le thème metamorphosis
l'exposition est une invitation à
réfléchir sur la place toujours
grandissante de la technologie de
l'autre dont vit dans une heure assez à
la fois que certaines personnes peuvent
se trouver inquiétante mais aussi assez
intéressante avec le tout le
développement technologique qui que l'on
vit présentement les piles monde de
l'art est un reflet de tout simplement
finalement dans la salle centrale
l'exposition jardins intérieurs un peu
de chaleur au milieu de l'hiver on y
présente 23 oeuvres d'artistes locaux et
internationaux des acquisitions récentes
ce une réflexion sur ce confinement qui
nous a forcés à chercher à l'intérieur
de nous la beauté et l'imagination
durant le temps du confinement alors
maintenant qu'on peut retourner dans les
galeries pourquoi s'en priver sinet bien
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal